she's a marsupial so that's what they do
when they're babies they hang out in
their mom's pouch and that keeps them
safe and they go in there and they nurse
and they actually are born almost like
fetuses they don't have fur they don't
have eyes they just have two little legs
and they are born they have to crawl
into the pouch where they nurse eating
my microphone
part of the natural order for these uh
it's about the same size in the shape as
her mother's nipple so that's probably
what she thinks is going on there that's
so sad she was like Mama's nipple and it
was a microphone well it didn't get it
didn't give her anything so she gave up
on it that's the cruelest prank of all
what a sweetie pie and this is so you
can these are little claw foot these are
her big old kangaroo feet that's that's
her ankle right there this is the ankle
this is you know her toes so you know
these animals have to be able to hop at
really really fast speeds
oh
well when they're babies she's about
five months old um anywhere from you
know six months to almost almost a year
they'll stay in that pouch did they ever
if they don't if they fail in the world
move back into their pouch no actually
believe it or not believe it out there
posters again from college yeah believe
it or not the older the older babies
once the the you know their their
siblings come along the older ones still
try to get back in there for as long as
they possibly can because I mean it's
safe it's warm free Transportation yeah
free grub that's what everybody wants
but um but yeah you know the females um
as cute as these these guys are am I
making the right sounds by the way ah
I'm just randomly picking noises I don't
know what will be the most soothing
I think it's working because she's
totally relaxing your arms there right
so yeah so yeah but these these you know
the mothers when they are being
threatened they actually do something a
little bit gruesome and that is um say
if a dingo is chasing after you know one
of these wallabies
um to make a meal of it and the mother
gets really stretched she will actually
push the baby out of her pouch as kind
of a sacrificial lamb and then she gets
to go on and have another baby so nature
you know red and tooth and Claw so wait
a minute the the mom says uh oh dingo
gaining on me have my baby yeah pretty
much pretty much yeah oh my God what
kind of creep I don't cover her ears
right no no no no no no no
uh what a beautiful animal really sweet
yeah very very sweet does this animal
have a pouch she does actually this is a
female females have pouches females have
pouches males don't and actually if you
want to feel around in there you might
be able to find it
did you read my Craigslist ad what's
your problem
go ahead and feed him a carrot this is a
kit do I throw the carrot and just put
it right by his mouth okay and then
he'll become your best friend oh nice
this is this huge animal is actually a
baby he's only a few weeks old let's
this is a few weeks old he's only a few
weeks old hey hey take it easy there
you'll get your carrots there you go and
the plan was take it easy there hey hold
on there camel no that's glass you can't
eat glass well I cannot feed this thing
fast enough
[Applause]
all right
here here I'm sorry whoa sorry sorry
okay
all right
here oh the flat of my hand okay is that
what it's yelling yeah how does Andy
understand camel no actually that that
should do the trick all right let's
let's keep him over here here let me
it's over here
hold on there pal I'm your friend
remember I'm the one that fed you so
this guy this is the bad guy who didn't
feed you
what an incredible sound yeah the plan
was actually to feed him his bottle but
he just decided this week that he was
done with the bottle now he wants real
solid food so luckily well now we're out
of carrots I was going to say luckily
we're out we're out of carrots and it's
getting very angry apples does it eat
anything else
microphone I don't know we have
gum I don't know we have what are we
gonna do okay I think
[Music]
probably a good time why don't you pick
up some of these carrots here yeah I'll
pick up some carrots and then I think
Dave will it yeah will that work yeah we
got we got apples will apples work David
oh yeah he'll probably try an apple I
got an Apple share
what about this you want an apple to
give I'm afraid this is we're probably
gonna have to get him uh to for more
food yeah I think he's probably I think
he's probably done okay I think he's
done ladies and gentlemen that was okay
uh foreign
animal friends that's right so this is a
Capuchin monkey and we're gonna bring
out his friend right now who is
completely unlucky it's an animal that
if they existed in the wild together
would probably eat him okay we're gonna
put this caracal right on the desk here
you might want to stand up this is oh
yeah because it might attack me well you
know may I pet it or yeah let me give
him a pet there yeah this is a caracal
it's a caracal it's an African wild cat
and they they hate each other in real
life in real life they probably would
kill each other oh he found the food
yeah that's Andy that's Andy's snack
right there
yeah we'll let him do this yeah in the
wild characters like to eat birds but
they would eat a monkey and so luckily
in the wild these guys live in South
America and those guys live in Africa
but they were raised together and
they're like best buddies when you say
race together like you got them an
apartment together
no okay I'm actually really glad you
said that because as cute as these guys
are both okay okay oh oh okay was that
okay yeah yeah he was just trying to get
he tried to mate with the caracal
he tried to give him a hug and that goes
against God it was it was all platonic
monkeys shall not lie down with cats I'm
glad you said that both of these animals
can you put them on me are very
no maybe not here hey look at that look
at that look at that I wish we had a
camera look at him he just figured out
who I was and he's not happy if you
offer him food he'll be your friend you
want to be my pal let me behind pal
huh see I swear all right did you see
that he thought he was on Ellen and then
he got a good look at me he loves
everybody I don't know what it is about
you no well he might sense evil uh right
there oh there we go there we go what's
the danger here what would be
what you want to pay attention to
obviously is that all of his body
postures tell me he's totally
comfortable with you but even at this
age a one-year-old you know
[Applause]
no I'm fine
there's lots of space on the couch no no
this Kitty made it quite clear
beautiful beautiful animal these guys my
favorite thing about these guys is that
they can actually catch birds out of the
air so if a bird was to fly over its
head oh it can leap in the air and open
the air and catch it should bring a bird
yeah
you guys want to be on this side I see a
cage a glove and a bowl of meat yes I'm
scared you're gonna step back and if
this animal comes close just stay behind
me all right all right we ready
this is a cape vulture this is a vault
this is the velociraptor look at the
claws let's see if we can get him up
here on the stage hey
he's looking the other way there we go
now he's going to aggressively come for
this meat so don't let him see that
meatball oh
why did you give me why did you give me
a meatball and then say don't let him
see that you have a meatball you don't
want to let him see it so that he jumps
on you so you kind of hide behind me
there right so just hold it near my face
there we go okay hey pal away from the
audience yeah now these guys are
scavengers which is why okay I'm unhappy
now
see
there we go all right there we go now
he's back where we want them so these
guys are they're scavengers they eat
carrion that other animals have killed
and they have to be really aggressive
there I'll bring him back over this way
okay I think he's lost interest yeah so
do people usually when they're
confronting these animals what were the
bowls of meat is that the idea
so normally you wouldn't confront this
animal but no no but these guys have to
bring it on a television show
these guys like they have to fight off
their other vultures when they're
actually going after a kill so um you
know dead carrying animal okay and
that's why you see him being so
aggressive
normally
all right I'm gonna uh we're out of time
and I sense that death is imminent so
I'm gonna put my bowl over there